sally is an architect who creates a
blueprint of a rectangular dining room
the area of the actual dining room is
1600 times larger than the area of the
dining room on the blueprint the length
of the dining room on the blueprint is
three inches
what is the length of the actual dining
room in feet
so there's a couple of really
interesting things going on here they
give us the dimensions on the blueprint
in inches we want the actual length in
feet and then they tell us that the area
of the actual dining room is 1600 times
larger so they're not saying that the
scale of the blueprint is at 1 1600 it's
going to be something less than that and
let's think about what that scale is
going to be
and so let's just let's just prac let's
just think about some different scales
let's say i have something let's say my
let's say that my this is my blueprint
and this is
the actual reality of the dining room
that we're thinking about
now if and my blueprint is let's just
say one by one just just for the sake of
sake of argument
now if this was a one by one
a square
and we increased the dimensions we
increased the dimensions
by a factor of
by a factor of two
so we increased it by a factor of two so
it's a two
by two square what's the what's the area
going to be well this area is going to
be four this area is one this area is
four so you notice that if we increase
by a factor of two it increase our area
by a factor of 4. or another way of
saying if we increase our each of our
dimensions by a factor of 2 we're going
to increase our area by a factor of 4.
if instead we increased our
our each of our dimensions by a factor
of three
by a factor of three this would be a
three by three square and we would
increase our area by a factor by a
factor of nine
so notice whatever factor we're
increasing the area by
it's going to be the factor that we're
increasing the dimensions by
squared so let's just think about it
that way so they're telling us that
we're increasing the the area by 1600
times so actually let me just clean this
thing up a little bit
so
one way we could imagine it if our
drawing
if our drawn drawing did have an area of
one which we can't assume but we could
for the sake of just figuring out how
much we have to
what the scale of the drawing is so let
me clear all of this here
let me clear that
so
the area of of the actual dining room
is sixteen hundred times larger and so
if this if the if the drawing had an
area of one then the area of the actual
dining room would be sixteen hundred so
what would i have to multiply each of
the dimensions by to get a area factor
of sixteen hundred
well if i multiply this dimension by
forty
and this dimension by forty we see 40
times 40 is 1600 you might say hey sal
how did you figure out 40 well the 16 is
a big clue we know that 4 times 4 is
equal to 16.
and so if you gave a zero to each of
these fours if you made it 40 times 40
then that is going to be 1600
so this information right over here
tells us that the scale factor of the
dimensions of of the two of the the
lengths i should say that that scale
factor is 40 that would result in a
scale factor for the area of
so that's a good starting point now
let's go to the actual dining room on
the blueprint so the actual dining room
of the blueprint doesn't have these
dimensions we just use that to figure
out the scaling factor the actual dining
room on the blueprint has a length of
three inches
so maybe it looks something like this
and they don't give us any of the other
dimensions so we can even imagine a
three inch
by we could buy two inch one inch
whatever we want but we can even imagine
a three inch by three inch
three inch by three square they only
care about the length now let's multiply
both of these by a factor of 40. we only
care about the length here they actually
say what's the length of the actual
dining room
so let's multiply it
and obviously this is not drawn to scale
let's multiply this times a factor of 40
times a factor
of 40. so 3 times 40 is 120 3 times 40
is 120 and this of course is what we're
referring to as the length now you might
be tempted to say okay we're done this
will be 120 but remember this is 120
this is 120 inches
120 inches
so what is 120 inches in terms of feet
well one foot
one foot is equal to 12
12 inches
if you were to multiply both of these
times 10 we we know that 10 feet
10 feet is equal to
120 inches or another way you could have
thought about it you have 120 inches
divided by 12 feet
divided by 12 inches per foot is going
to give you 10. so 120 divided by 120
inches let me write it this way
120 inches divided by
inches per foot
is going to give you
10 feet so that's the actual length of
the dining room and feet